i am wonder mike and i've come to say
hello to the black to the white the red
and the brown
the purple and yellow but first you've
got a bang bang boogie to the boogie
of this beat that i've got here you're
so white this is a new song
from tom mcdonald you may have heard of
tom mcdonald
he is a rapper from british columbia
and he had a song called fake woke that
came out at the end of january
and it jumped to the top of the charts
now you know i'm not
totally down with the hip-hop you know
all the time man i'm not like going into
the clubs and
how do you do fellow kids but wherever
people listen to hip-hop
but i did take notice of this at the
time i said oh my gosh that's very
impressive
and now he's got another song that's
come out and that has
jumped to the top of the charts that
song is called snowflakes
i'm going to take all of my pop culture
knowledge
and expertise i'm going to channel it
into examining this video
before we get into it just want you to
remember this video is sponsored by acre
gold
the new way to buy gold more from them
later
first let's get to the hippity hop
if you lie to the government they'll put
you in prison when they lie to all of us
it's called being a politician you think
taking guns away will save our kids from
the killings but your pro-choice
abortion kills way more children if
america's so terrible and racist
it probably isn't safe to encourage
immigration just saying
all the contradictions are embarrassing
you know who hates america the most
americans trigger warnings
and now they're everywhere to protect
millennials feelings he she
his him hers them they screw a pronoun
because everyone
hey blair white look at that hatred
but hating straight men white folks and
christians is common coca-cola telling
people they should be less white they
preach intolerance but if you disagree
they fight there's a race war here
elections based on fear black lives only
matter once every four years soldiers
died for this
welfare to country bombs and forget
about the veterans black folks and white
folks divided by the news but we are all
the same we are red white and blue
ashamed to be american okay that's cool
cause honestly
we are all ashamed of you two dollars so
fake
like the idea that blair white has this
like super deep voice
[Music]
they set us up to fail that's what they
built the system for put an ammunition
shop across the street from a liquor
store
empowering women used to be different
than this before the role models got
only fans or dance on a stripper pole
screw it i ain't tripping i don't mean
to be mean but if our children are the
future then our future is bleak they
taking adderall to focus hit mcdonald's
to eat
they're addicted to phones and they take
xanax to sleep they blur the lines
dividing communism and democracy in 2021
we paint the patriots as nazis the men
playing women's sports gets hopies for
winning
like great let's celebrate a man for
beating some women if you're black your
life matters you're supposed to embrace
it if you're rich or you're smart then
you're probably asian
if you're gay then you're brave all of
that i'm okay with but if you're white
the stereotype is you are a race all
right let's pause it there let's pause
it there so
this is actually very interesting
lyrics right the lyrics here are making
very good points but they're kind of
undercutting themselves
right he's making all these great points
about how we used to view women in a
certain
way but now we view women in this very
degraded way you know because if they're
only fans and online porn and stuff but
then who's the woman in the video
the woman in the video is blaire white
who's not a woman blair is a man i like
blair
very much a nice guy but isn't that part
of the problem
isn't that you know the same thing with
the degraded culture and everything
i i love that if someone is going to
listen to hip hop
that they're going to be listening to
this they should be listening to this
over 99 of the other hip-hop out there
but i guess the question for
conservatives is our can we win at this
game can we win
at the hip-hop game can we win at the
pop culture or are we can we win
at saying our transsexuals are more
attractive than your transsexuals i
remember there was a meme going around
that was juxtaposing caitlyn caitlin
jenner you know bruce jenner
with that guy who wears a wig and he
says he's a woman at the health
department in the federal government
and the memes said you know our
transsexuals are more attractive than
yours or something
and you think okay like maybe i don't
again i'm not exactly a great judge of
that
but even if that's the case you're
accepting the left's
premise so are you still are you really
going to win or are you just kind of
trying to grab a little ground around
the edges but ultimately
you're playing on the left's turf when
you're playing on the left turf things
are going to get a little bit crazy as
we see in the culture and one way to
protect against that acre gold acre gold
a great way to buy
gold acre lets you subscribe to gold
bars for as little as 30
a month michael you say gold costs more
than 30
you're right however acres figured this
out
you don't need to come out of pocket all
at once you pay each month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship acre gold to your house just
recently
acre has introduced a new 100 a month
subscription to a 5 gram gold bar acre
keeps you updated on your gold stash
every single month
and ships discreetly to your door once
you reach that price threshold acre
allows you to take physical delivery of
your gold means it's safe
it's sound it's in your hands it's
designed in california sourced from one
of the largest mints in switzerland
i love it i am invested in acre gold
they make it super easy head on over to
get acre gold.com
knowles start investing in physical gold
today make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for this giveaway you got to
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre that
is getangergold.com
i also want to thank you aker gold for
supporting the show
all right let's keep going with the
hip-hop that's the reason things are
tough while you tweet from an iphone and
sip on a starbucks you're supporting
what you stand against you don't think
you are but
a percocet addict don't donate money to
pharma damn dog we're all afraid to
speak the truth and the more afraid we
get the more we hate the ones who do
you're ashamed to be american okay
that's cool cause honestly
we are all ashamed of you two dollars
oh no the forecast said that there be
snowflakes
whoa
[Music]
the blair thing is really freaking me
out i don't
because that's supposed to be that's the
role of like the sexy woman in the thing
but
blair's a guy everybody's wrong that's a
real problem hey they don't want to hear
it but they still
talking soon enough we running out of
options
this ain't gonna end till it's in the
coffin we ain't gonna be friends till we
try to squash it
i don't know how we can make a man so we
dropping snowflakes melt when it's hot
kid
y'all are so fake oh no
the forecast said that there be
snowflakes
whoa you can make us see
it your
[Music]
all right so there's no more snowflakes
and yet there are you know obviously
we're living in the sort of snowflake
woke whatever
we want to call it culture so that is
what's what's dominating and yet somehow
this song jumps to number one on the
charts how is that possible this
is the complicating factor for
conservatives here
because given the current culture we
live in
i would much rather people be listening
to that and watching that than basically
anything else they could listen to or
watch
right of course i encourage that give me
more of that that's cool makes me feel
encouraged for the culture that that
jumps to number one
instead of i don't know i have truly no
frame of reference but some other stupid
hip-hop song that's left-wing okay good
but then on the other hand you say wait
a second is conservatism now
is the thing we're conserving like
hip-hop
and transgenderism and
what are what we what exactly are we
conserving here
my take on it is this is a good start
this is a good start in that you have a
culture then you had the left come in
with the anti-culture and destroy that
culture it's right it's
i'm not being hyperbolic i'm not just
trying to throw bombs here i'm saying
the actual purpose of
political correctness wokeness cancel
culture is cancel culture right is to
is to destroy something it's to tear
down the statues
it's to burn down the buildings it's to
debunk the past and the philosophy right
it's to
it's just purely negative and so because
we're caught up in this whirlwind of
destruction
we need some way out of that so i see a
video like this come along
and a rapper like this come along and i
think okay or and blair white actually
in this example who is also
deconstructing gender who's also
deconstructing like the whole thing
is kind of destructive but they're
aiming the cannons of destruction
at the very anti-culture that's
destroying the original culture stay
with me
so you've got the this kind of
play by their play their game but beat
them at it right you've got this pl
turn their game against them on
questions of sex on questions of music
on questions of culture
on questions of art on all of these
things how the turntables
so i'm all in for that first step but
then you've got to build something
right then you've got to say certain
things are true you speak the true truth
this type of art is more beautiful than
this sort of art
this is a man this is a woman this
is what america stands for not just this
is not what america stands for
not just this is what america's ashamed
of but this is actually
the positive vision we're putting out in
the world
good first step now we need to offer
something
edifying let me know what you think of
the song if you enjoy
my brilliant analysis of it i'm just
going to speak for you here and say that
you believe it's brilliant
uh post other videos that you want me to
react to in the comments below we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you